nice and short for you all so I don't
take much time from you but I'm gonna
give you some context first okay
um if you've been watching the previous
videos you know what I think about the
current price action often that we are
in this range okay this is your Range
High this is your range lows your
mid-range and these are the quarters of
the range okay they are marked the
quarters of range because you can see
how they've been playing out pretty
nicely okay you have here support
support support
okay and then in the other side you have
here resistance resistance resistance of
support but then it first immediately
again while actually resistance with
range highs okay so you can see that
they are playing up pretty nicely the
range quarters okay now if you're going
to the one hour time frame yesterday we
were talking about the idea
that this boom here okay was building
the Asian session so we've done through
pumps during these in sessions okay
that's one of the keys of this trading
system okay and that's a very high
priority trade we usually take it and we
say that when Asia pumps the most likely
thing is that it gets retraced within 24
hours
why because you have the New York
session
and if it doesn't get retraced during
the New York session then it gets free
traced during the next Asian session
okay that played out in fact London
retraced this pump okay so I'm glad I
play it out and also you can see that
this price action okay what happened
here is that that's an aviation above
the rain size okay that's something that
we've been talking up for you know
several days we are expecting a
deviation above range size okay and then
a breakout below this range okay
now the problem that I see here is that
I'm not sure
if this is enough okay 31 500 by the way
notice something okay check out this
week check out this week okay the week
are the highs Thirty one thousand five
hundred zero zero okay
and the week are the lows
twenty nine thousand five hundred zero
zero that's an awkward incidence okay
that's a footprint from the market maker
okay so you can see how they are set in
the range with psychological round
numbers okay 29 500 and 31 500. simple
as that now four hour time frame what do
we see in the four hour time frame well
uh yesterday okay we cut this from the
sensation and then the retrace within
the London session the problem with that
rate is that it left a long week behind
okay here you have the 50 of the week
and the 100 of the week the system says
that at least the 50 of the week has to
get retraced so I'm not considering
the idea of leaving the range
before filling this week over here okay
this week over here has to get filled
now the question is is it going to get
filled at 50 attempt or is he actually
Gonna Fill the hundred percent and then
even sweep this High second
all right that's the question that you
have to ask yourself
um I did that already
so I'm going to tell you my opinion
later in the video but let's continue
with the price action okay so we all
understand the context
so Asia pumped London retraced and what
do we have here okay during the London
Retreat you can see this week to the
downside okay they fill the week here
you go so let me remove it but also they
filled the 50 of this week over here
that we've been talking also for some
days okay so this week here
also removed
all right now
but the system is saying that once they
fill the 50 of the week there is a
chance that they don't come all the way
to the hundred percent because if they
feel the 50 then we consider that week
to get filled
all right
now can I still go to 100 of course yes
but for that then we need you know some
consolidation here because if you don't
see an immediate reaction here and a
push higher then you can consider the
idea that if there is a consolidation
here and wouldn't see a reaction then we
see another electron fill the hundred
percent
maybe even you know deviate again from
the lows and then you can see you know
another leg up so uh that's the scenario
about this 100 of the week that some of
you asked me in Twitter yesterday that's
what I think now what do I think is
going to happen next I look at the chart
okay we are right now above the range
quarter
so then naturally I'm failing higher
prices
do you understand and what I'm going to
favor I'm going to favor at least the 50
of this week at 31 171.
okay from here
it will be around four percent pump now
of course I I don't think it's gonna
happen today I don't think it's very
likely Fridays tend to be quite uh quiet
at least you know in the past weeks but
we'll see what happens okay but that's
going to be the scenario that I'm going
to think for next week so that's a
little less spoiler for the Sunday
update
okay now
today we have
um known foreign payrolls a half 12
UTC time that's an hour and a half from
now okay so if the labor market is still
very strong we could see you know the
Stock Market opening in red
I'm Bitcoin should then follow that's
the only chance that I see
really for Bitcoin to come lower until
this week before coming back to this one
okay now in the opposite if there if the
results are not bad then we might see
some consolidation today okay or if the
results are actually really good and the
labor market is cooling down they would
see Bitcoin taking a nice you know move
to the upside why not
here at the mid-range I'm expecting some
kind of resistance but I think
eventually we'll flip it okay tested a
support and that is another opportunity
to Long towards this target so that's
what I think at the moment also
we're gonna go now through high block
Capital we're gonna see where the
liquidity is in the chart but
I think that this one over here I think
I saw it yesterday 31 700
that song is still an interesting zone
for Bitcoin
we're in hablo Capital let's have a look
at the monthly
time frame okay liquidation hit map one
month time frame let's have a look by
arms guessing that is still there is
called a lot of liquidity over there
okay check this out
look at that yellow bar Thirty One
Thousand seven hundred yes you know we
talked this one at 31 600 a bar why you
know they didn't pump another 100 or 200
you know take all of these liquidations
and then dump price
why well I talked about this in
yesterday's video but
when they do this
uh to miss a strategy
to build more liquidity up here you can
even see the yellow bar getting brighter
okay so
um take these numbers with a pinch of
salt because uh high blood Capital
doesn't reduce them okay doesn't reduce
this number it can only uh because they
don't know when Traders are closing the
position so you only increase this
number can only increase for them okay
but now you have 23 billions seven
hundred dollars worth of liquidations
okay yesterday at that exact point you
had 22 volumes okay so you can see how
increased okay a five percent that
number now could this be a strategy this
dump here okay to make the retail Trader
believe that we're going to say lower
prices so they open shorts okay and
those liquidations are going to be
stacked in this one here So eventually
this number here 31 700.
it's gonna have more liquidity than
before so if they now bring price up
again and hit this Zone they're gonna
hit a lot more liquidations
do you understand what I mean so in a
way it's bringing price down you know
before bringing it back up
to hit a lot more liquidity than they
could have done previously okay that's
what I think that's what I think the 31
700 is not off the table
even if we miss it for you know two
hundred dollars it's not off the table
guys to be cautious with that okay now
let's go back to the Chart so guys
Bitcoin
the asymptom has been retraced as we
thought now the problem is that it left
a long week behind this week needs to
get filled okay so that's going to be
our next Target because the week
students that have been filled except
100 of this week but for now we're Above
This range quarter as long as we hold
above it one favoring higher prices
now we have you know in one hour the
non-farm payrolls let's see how that
plays out because if the results are bad
there is a chance that we revisit this
range lows okay before coming back up
that's what I think again I don't think
we're gonna break below this range
sorry without filling this week first
okay that's right now uh what I think
also uh if
if
we come to the 50 of the week okay to
this one I'm very scene of momentum or
Target is going to be it's not going to
be the 100 of the week it's not going to
be the range size it's going to be this
liquidation Zone over here a 31 700 that
we just saw in high block capital okay
so be cautious guys again uh I don't
think that today we're gonna see uh
major poom but you know I would suggest
you to avoid trading during the news
announcement during the non-farm payroll
wait 30 minutes 45 minutes after that
data comes out and then you can trade
otherwise you might get caught in
volatility do you know the position
might be stopped and then really nothing
happens in this Zone okay that's another
possibility and now if you're going to
lower time frame 15 minutes time frame
check this out okay I just noticed this
you have here a potential three tops
button okay this is your first stop
this is your second Tab and this is your
third tab check it out okay when there
is a Philly tops button When You're
Expecting is some kind of reversal okay
in this time it will be to the upside
now if you go if you inverse the chart
wouldn't you show this structure look at
that you can see again the three tops
button down to the upside okay because
the chart is invest
but wouldn't you short this okay uh this
is what I mean also you know we are
right now
above the range quarter and we have this
structure we have a work to the upside
the chart is a little bit too long here
but
I must wait until the non-farm payroll's
data is out because again there is a
chance that we see a dump here to the
range flows if the data is bad
and invalidate this structure here this
is the tops button okay
but again
it's valid until invalidated away right
so the structure is bullish at the
moment we might come today to this range
meet today okay that's a you know 300
400 dollars pump you know that's a nice
trade still for a Friday but uh in the
midterm with the midterm I talk about
you know within one week two weeks I'm
expecting Bitcoin to revisit this week
to the upset in the four hours time
frame okay so that's pretty much
everything guys
thank you so much for watching I might
upload an update about the altcoin
market this weekend I'll see how I feel
I might cover this I mean if you want me
to cover this and also before I finish
the video let me show you something
So for anybody that missed this okay I
have a trading course uh I've had it
since February we've already had around
300 students okay and this is my website
clipping.com uh here you have some uh
questions and answers also in course
details you can see the overview and the
content what you're going to learn and
then in courses okay we released this on
Monday and we have two groups per month
August is fully booked you go fully
booked in the same day and now we have
September and October October has a
discount for anticipation and September
is getting booked pretty quickly
uh you can see that the stock is only
for example 10 courses left we started
with 40 each group so uh we we expect
the the courses get fully booked uh
probably by the end of next week or even
this week we'll see how uh that works
but anyway I tell you this in case you
know you've been following me for quite
some time I do want to engage with the
course so don't miss out because it's
likely that it gets uh sold out again
very soon okay so anyway guys that's
pretty much everything thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you soon